You mean Antz?
The movie Jeffrey Katzenberg had made in three
months because he left Disney and said, "They're
putting out a movie about ants.
Let's make a movie about ants.
We'll call it Antz.
Slap a Z on it for the kids.
We'll put a Z on it, Kids love Zs!
They're fun.
Tom, Tom, Tom.
Tom.
What are some of the most underrated animated
movies ever?
Brian, I'm glad you came to me with this one.
Only one example came to mind.
We had a bunch on the list and I think the
problem with a lot of animated movies is that
there's no way for them to be underrated.
They tend to have fan bases that that will
very sternly rate them without going over
or under, with the following exception, the
Lego Batman Movie from 2017.
If you haven't seen it-
It's awesome.
... liked it more than the actual Lego Movie,
which is a very sweet film.
Liked it more than most Batman movies and
I'm a huge Batman fan.
It is just brilliant.
It was written by a handful of Community and
American Dad writers.
It paints the Batman-Joker dynamic as just
shy of romantic, where Batman isn't ready
to settle down and just have one nemesis.
He wants to nemesis around.
He wants to spread his nemesis far and wide
and that really hurts the joker.
It is just beautifully done.
It's brilliant.
It's one of my all-time favorite movies.
Always in a better mood after I watch it.
I saw it in the theaters and I liked it.
I remember liking it, but I've been casually
interested in revisiting it versus the original
Lego Movie, which I loved.
Yeah, that's interesting.
The Lego Batman Movie is good.
Really good.
Yes.
But you say it's better than good.
It's frenetic and constant and I love it.
The cast is stacked.
The best part of the whole thing, besides
the fact that the have Ralph Fiennes playing
Alfred the Butler and then later on, Voldemort
shows up.
They don't have him voice him.
They have Ed Izzard do it.
The best part is the part that never actually
got to happen.
We found out earlier this year that they were
going to make a sequel that never came around,
but it was Michael Waldron, the show runner
on Loki and Dan Harmon wrote the sequel.
I didn't hear about this.
You didn't hear?
Oh, man.
Okay.
I don't remember it.
Tell us about it.
The problem was that while Warner brothers
still has all of the DC character rights,
Universal got the rights to the Lego franchise.
Right.
last year.
I remember this happening.
It killed the sequel.
It was a rights dispute that went across toys
and superhero contracts.
Right, but they put out the first page of
the sequel.
The title of the sequel that Dan Harmon and
Michael Waldron wrote is Lego Super Friends
based on the Lego Batman Movie based on the
Lego Movie, based on the Lego line of toys,
which we were probably based on Lincoln Logs,
also based on the DC Comics' character, Batman,
also based on the DC Comics' character, Superman.
Also based on the DC Comics' Character, Aquaman.
Also based on the DC Comics' characters, the
Wonder Twins.
Also loosely based on Boogie Nights, based
on the cartoon, Super Friends, based on an
original idea by Dan Harmon and Michael Waldron.
Just incredible.
Hats off to everybody involved.
Perfection.
Yeah.
That's a good pick.
Maybe someday it will happen.
You never know.
Good pick.
All right.
Nina, what about you?
What's the most underrated animated movie
that you could think of?
Tom made a really good point that I was also
kind of going to touch on, which is that I
think you go into...
I went into this thinking my original pick
was underrated and then I was like, Spirited
Away won the Academy Award for Best Animated
Feature.
It is rated correctly because it's a great
movie and I love it.
It is not underrated.
It's exactly right.
Yes, and so I kind of was thinking about it
some more and I revisited a different Hayao
Miyazaki movie that I watched a lot as a kid
and that movie is Princess Mononoke.
Are either of you familiar with Princess Mononoke?
I am vaguely familiar with both of those,
but I will fully admit that I watched one
of them and I don't remember which one it
was.
Bad luck, Brian.
Once on a date and that was how it
Well, they're different centuries.
Spirited Away came out in the 2000s, so if
this could fix you at any point in time, I
This was back in 1845 when I was -
Yeah.
You went got to the movie theater in a cart
pulled by some oxen.
Before the movie they showed, they showed
the train going through and I got really scared.
Perfect.
Great ambiance for Miyazaki.
Princess Mononoke is the older of the two.
It came out in 1997 and what they've done
with pretty much, I think all, but I could
be wrong.
You can feel free to run a retraction under
me if I am, with pretty much all of Miyazaki's
movies, I think that they have pretty much
immediately dubbed them into English.
You have the Japanese version and then you
have the version with an American cast.
For example, in Spirited Away, the girl from
The Ring, I think, was the voice of Sen, the
main character.
I think you're right.
Princess Mononoke was a movie I watched a
lot as a kid, which upon revisiting it, I'm
like, why did my parents let me watch this?
Because it's kind of viscerally gruesome.
It's a movie warning about the dangers of
deforestation and climate change, so it's
very weirdly so relevant today, but the American
voice cast is ridiculous.
It's Billy Crudup, Claire Danes, Billy Bob
Thornton, Minnie Driver, Jada Pinkett-Smith.
You keep hearing voices and you're like, "Oh,
I know exactly who that is."
Basically, it's about a prince who's the last
of his line named Ashitaka, who he gets cursed
by a demon after he tries to save himself
in battle with it.
He basically has to go into the center of
the forest.
He meets a girl named San, who was raised
by wolves and lives amongst them.
It's a warning tale about let's not knock
down all the forests and build iron in its
place because we're going to destroy the earth,
but really good movie, really good performances
by the American voice gas.
Obviously, it looks incredible because it's
Hayao Miyazaki, who's a genius.
I just remember being like, "Wow, this movie
still holds up."
It sent all the neurons in my brain firing
to revisit some of the scenes because I was
like, "Oh, I haven't watched this since I
was a kid."
Miyazaki's whole collection is on HBO Max
now, so it's very accessible to anybody who
is not familiar with it.
It was a big deal because I don't think they
were streaming for years and then finally,
HBO Max got catalog rights, but good movie.
Still has some solid jokes in it, but there's
a lot of kind of weird demon possession happening
in it.
The way demons are represented is these gross
worm things will just grow out of a giant
boar.
I just remember being like ... I watched this
when I was eight, like a lot.
I apparently could still sleep at night.
That's very weird.
So you could sound watch The Thing?
Probably.
It's got some weird, unsettling imagery.
Would not recommend it for a child under 10,
which is ironic considering when I watched
it, but really good movie.
Really holds up and I feel like, especially
even in Miyazaki's catalog, I think people
forget about it a lot compared to Howl's Moving
Castle or Spirited Away.
Right.
My Neighbor Tototoro.
Go watch this movie on HBO Max.
It's really good.
I had a blast revisiting it.
Interesting.
That's good to know that they're on HBO Max.
Now I have something to check out.
Yeah some of the movies on this list on looper.com,
I have actually seen in theaters.
Some of them, I don't remember much about,
but I would probably argue that they're underrated.
Titan A.E.
Did either of you see that one?
Yeah.
Unfamiliar.
I saw that when it came out in theaters.
That's a Matt Damon joint.
I think they animated him with the Mushroom
cut.
Did that run at the beginning of it?
A Matt Damon joint.
Is he ripping off Spike Lee entirely now?
No, that's definitely the one where if you
can look it up on YouTube, you can rent movies
on YouTube, it looks like they found the worst
fan art on the internet to use as the poster.
It doesn't look like Dreamworks, or whoever
made the movie...
It can't be the official poster for this thing.
It's just this nightmare.
Oh, yeah.
Look at that.
That's real bad.
I'm going to share that in our chat.
Do you see?
No.
It looks like MS Paint 201.
This is my final project.
It's so bad.
Oh, God.
Much worse than the movie would
This looks like it-
The movie was pretty good!
This looks like it wouldn't have made the
cut for a Carmen Sandiego CD-ROM game, many
of which I played and they had terrible graphics.
Titan A.E. is like a space adventure.
It's fun.
It's got Nathan Lane as a catty, mean alien,
which is
Nice.
Nathan Lane.
I remember it being pretty good and that it
just also faded away.
Another movie in a similar vein, Treasure
Planet.
I think Atlantis and Treasure Planet are both
two sides of the same coin.
They're big budget Disney animated adventures
geared towards young men.
There's not so much princesses in it.
not so many talking animals.
I remember watching Atlantis at least a couple
times.
I probably had that one on VHS.
Atlantis, I remember reading an article about
it not too long ago on, I think it was Polygon.
It goes into detail about how the guy who
created Hellboy, Mike Mignola actually.
Mike Mignola, yeah.
He did a bunch of the designs for that movie.
One of the reasons why they have such a specific
look is that they're basically Disnifying
Mike Mignola's weird, creepy artwork.
Treasure Planet, another.
Treasure Island in Space.
Sure, why not?
I remember it being pretty good and then I
also don't remember anything else about it.
I think did David Hyde Pierce plays a FOP
in it?
He's just a FOP-ish alien.
No, he nailed it.
Prince of Egypt, I remember enjoying a bunch
because I am a Jewish person and it tells
the story of Passover.
Filled with X-Men energy though, just wild-
Yeah.
With songs, and excitement, and drama, and Sandra
Bullock and Jeff Goldblum and Val Kilmer,
so that's important.
Road to El Dorado is on here.
I started that one because I read that it
was apparently very good, but I-
I watched that movie all the time.
I remember it very well.
Was that movie super duper funny and good?
It was pretty funny.
I remember that was on in the house a lot
when I was a young and a youth.
It's Kevin Kline and who else?
Kenneth Branagh.
Yes.
Is that right?
Oh, that's very
Sir, Sir Kenneth Branagh.
Sir Kenneth Branagh.
There's some good memes from that movie that
are floating around, but the two that I'm
going to talk about specifically are the ones
that I really, really do love.
Now, one of them that's on this list of underrated
and it's probably underrated because if you
ask the average person whether or not they've
seen this movie, they'll probably be like,
"No, what's that?"
If you ask any fan of animation or animated
movies, they'll be like, "Yes, that's an amazing
movie.
Why are you even asking me about it?"
It's The Iron Giant.
This is a movie that flopped when it came
out and it just holds up because it's amazing.
It'll break your heart.
It's one of the few movies that can reliably
get me very emotional by the end.
Oh, man.
What a movie.
That was a Brad Bird joint, right?
If we're-
that's how it started.
Did that kickstart him as a powerhouse in
animation because then he went on to do stuff
like The Incredibles and Ratatouille, and
some of the greatest modern-
It was before those things.
Well, it was obviously before those, but yeah,
I mean, I would imagine that put him on the
map for animators in general.
I think for the people who knew what was what,
they were like, "Oh, this movie by this guy,
Brad Bird, it may not have done very well,
but we need to get him making movies for us
and do a good marketing budget and, but yeah.
If anyone watching this hasn't seen The Iron
Giant, I strongly suggest that you watch it
as soon as possible.
Basically, it takes place during the Cold
War in America, 1950s America's.
It's got this young kid and a single mom,
and the kid is just lonely and he's weird.
He needs a friend and then a giant killer
robot from space lands on Earth and he becomes
friends with it because it's lost its memory.
It grows and becomes this story about what
makes us who we are, what makes us human?
Do you have to be a human to be a human, or
if you're a human, does that automatically
mean you lose your humanity?
It's just this really great fable that it's
pretty much perfect from start to finish.
Again, fans of animation know this movie is
incredible, so it's not underrated in that
regard.
It's got great reviews.
It bombed when it came out though and if you've
never seen it, you might not know what's so
special about it.
I strongly urge you to see that one.
Quickly, it's the mark of Vin Diesel's first
voice role as a gentle giant, who would later
then play Groot because he voices a giant.
Pre-Groot.
Which I forgot about until just now, then
I looked it up.
Gentlest giant of all, Dominic Toretto, right?
He learned in Iron Giant, the importance of
family.
That's his last line as he flies up into the
sky with the nuke, family.
He goes fast, furious, family.
Is this when he was driving a car into space
in F9?
Which I have not seen yet, but I know happens.
Yeah.
He quotes The Iron Giant in that movie.
It all comes full circle.
The other movie on this list that I really
want to talk about that I absolutely adore
that I do think is underrated because I don't
think a lot of people have seen it is Batman:
Mask of the Phantasm.
I knew you were going to say that.
Now, Tom-
Really?
.. you mentioned Lego Batman as being one
of your favorite Batman movies.
Absolutely.
I contend, Batman: Mask of the Phantasm is
way better.
Fascinating.
And more underrated.
It's a very pretty movie.
It's so good.
By the way, Mike Mignola, don't know if you
know this, the guy that made Hellboy and also
Atlantis, just tying the whole thing together.
Also the guy that redesigned Mr. Freeze for
Batman, the animated series.
That sounds about right.
Changed him from a weird old bald man in a
fishbowl hat into this creepy...
Anyway, Batman: Mask of the Phantasm, I remember
when that came out and even as a child, it
was like, "Well this is a TV show.
Why is this going to the movie theater?"
I feel that's kind of what most audiences
thought, right?
The people who saw it thought that it was
great, but...
It was originally being made for release on
video, but then basically, I think it might
have been to fill a hole in the schedule or
maybe they just saw how it was shaping up,
they elevated it to a full theatrical release.
It really holds up.
It's got an amazing story.
It's got great voice acting, great set pieces.
There's an amazing fight with the Joker and
Batman and the Phantasm at the end that is
just like, I'll put this movie up against
any other Batman movie.
Until Christopher Nolan put out Batman Begins
and especially Dark Knight, this was the best
Batman.
I think that Lego Batman is probably like...
Do you like Adam West Batman?
Do you like silly Batman comic book stuff?
This is your Batman movie.
IT's very much divorced from the comics and
the original story, the grimness and really,
the characters.
Yeah.
Mask of the Phantasm delivers on basically,
the promise that the animated series had,
which was this serious, more dramatic, pulpy
adventure of Batman and this one delivers
on it because it's not that violence makes
things good, but when you're dealing with
a story that involves criminals, and killers,
and gangsters and psychotic clowns-
And a guy who punches them until they stop.
Yeah.
Violence kind of helps.
There's this villain out there, Phantasm,
who's basically dressed like the Grim Reaper,
out there bumping off mobsters and Batman
is trying to solve the crime, trying to solve
the mystery of who the Phantasm is and how
to stop it.
You get some insight into this world's Joker,
but before he became the joker, it's the only
piece of media in this animated universe that
goes into that.
It's just like this little, tiny bit and it's
just perfect.
It's so good.
One of my favorites.
Again, if you've never seen it, can't recommend
it enough.
I knew you were going to pick that and not
Antz with a Z.
Antz sucks.
Antz does suck.
It's not a good movie.
Sorry.
Antz starring Jennifer Lopez, Christopher
Walken and Woody Allen.
And Sylvester Stallone.
Oh, is he in that too?
You mean Antz, the movie Jeffrey Katzenberg
had made in three months because he left Disney
and said, "They're putting out a movie about
ants.
Let's make a movie about ants.
Well call it Antz.
Slap a Z on it for the kids.
Put a Z on it.
Kids love Zs.
They're fun.
Antz.
I'm sorry, list.
Antz-
Antz is bad.
Antz is a bad movie.
I'm going to say no to Antz on that one.
I'm trying to think if there's any other movies
I would add to this.
You know what I'm going to this list before
we go?
What's that?
Hit me.
I mentioned Prince of Egypt that I enjoy as
a Jewish person because it tells the story
of Passover and I like representation, but
to go on the complete opposite end of the
spectrum, I really like the movie Arthur Christmas.
I didn't know where you were going with that.
Okay.
It's a Christmas movie.
It's delightful.
Make me nervous.
I think it's wonderful.
James McAvoy, I'm pretty sure plays the titular
Arthur Christmas.
The titular role, yeah.
It's got Hugh Laurie as his big brother.
I don't remember his first name, probably
like Laurie Christmas or something.
Basically, the way that this world treats
Santa Claus is it's a thing you pass from
generation to generation, so Arthur is-
Is the-
Yeah, exactly.
So Arthur is the son of Santa Claus and he
just loves Christmas, but he's kind of clutz,
but he ends up saving Christmas at the end,
spoilers.
It's a really good animated movie that's probably
underrated.
I don't think a lot of people have seen it.
I got it on DVD as a gift a year ago and I.
I remember liking Anastasia a lot as a kid,
with Meg Ryan in the role, which luckily did
not end the way that Anastasia's real story
ended.
It doesn't start the way that Anastasia's
real story ended.
It's so bad.
Oh, stop it.
I was a kid.
I liked Anastasia.
Let me have this.
My sister loved that movie growing up, though
it's one of those ones...
And I feel like this happens with-
ethnic bat.
With the silly little bat.
It plays fast and loose with any fact whatsoever.
Christopher Lloyd, I think as Rasputin-
My favorite animated movie starring Meg Ryan,
John Cusack, and Kelsey Grammer.
The go-to names for children's entertainment.
Great voice acting.
Again, the kids loved Sleepless in Seattle
and When Harry Met Sally.
Cast Tom Hanks.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe.
See you later.